Are you using volume slash market profile analysis
in your futures trading?
If so, you need to watch this video.
Volume profile can be a useful tool,
but there's also some serious problems
with the underlying theories
behind this popular analysis method.
Keep in mind, volume profile was developed
over 30 years ago, like it's older than me,
and I'm getting quite a few gray hairs on my face here.
Our understanding of markets
has evolved considerably since that time.
Now that doesn't make volume profile useless,
far from it.
A few tweaks based on our modern understanding
of markets can make volume profile a powerful tool.
So, are you ready?
Let's get started.
Market profile is a form of analysis
pioneered in the 80s by J. Peter Steitelmeier,
and I have on good authority
that that guy is a total boss.
Like I asked around and everybody that traded with him
says he is one of the smartest people they ever met.
Then one of his students, John Dalton,
came along with his book, Mind Over Markets,
which really popularized the idea among retail traders.
Instead of your typical stock chart,
a market profile displays the market
as more of a histogram
to show how much time is spent at each price.
The trading day is split up into 30-minute sections
called time price opportunities
with each TPO being assigned a letter or a color.
The distribution then shows which TPO's touched that price.
It's more than just a really cool looking chart though.
The resulting graph usually shows
some sort of a Gaussian distribution,
which you would not expect in a purely random market.
The center of that distribution where the volume is highest
is called the point of control or POC.
You can further include the volume around that POC
until you have 70% of the day's volume
to define the value area of the day.
Now, as the data evolved,
we gained the ability to create
the same sort of histogram using a volume instead,
and the resulting volume profile
allows the same sort of analysis,
but on more granular data.
Some traders may prefer one over the other,
but volume profile and market profile
are largely interchangeable.
So yeah, don't let me confuse you if I mix terms around.
I'll probably say volume profile most of the time,
but same difference.
They're all based around
the same underlying theory of markets.
That theory at the heart of market profile analysis
is auction theory,
a theory for how markets move relative to value.
John Dalton describes this process
in the following manner in his book.
If the open is considered below value,
price auctions higher in search of sellers.
If the open is considered too high by market participants,
price auctions lower, searching for buyers.
Once a buyer enters the market,
price begins to auction upward
until the last buyer has bought.
Similarly, the market auctions downward
until the last seller has sold,
constantly searching for information.
So under this theory,
when market participants agree on fair value,
the market will stay in a range
of creating a distribution.
If fair value changes,
the market will auction up or down
in what is called range extension,
just like those auctions you see in movies.
Like Wreck-It Ralph 2 has a great example.
They keep bidding it up
until they realize how stupid they are.
Same thing happens in real markets,
but it auctions both ways at the same time.
If a new fair value is found,
the market will create a new distribution,
or that range extension move can be rejected,
forcing a test of the other side of the original range.
Most market profile practitioners
will then use this framework
together with past point of control,
value areas and related statistics
to try and predict where the market may go
during the trading day
and what prices they're interested in executing at.
So there's a lot to like about volume profile.
I feel like a lot of market philosophies
are based on conspiracy theories.
Maybe we'll talk about one of those next video.
But that's not the case
with auction theory.
It was created by serious market practitioners
based on real observations of the market.
Everyone that has traded seriously
can see it even if they can't quite put it into words.
Sometimes the market is dead
and you're bored out of your mind
and sometimes the trend just never ceases.
Volume profile also tries to utilize data and statistics
to create a consistent system.
You can get pretty far with some consistency
and smart risk management.
Something volume profile educators will emphasize a lot.
The edge maybe isn't so much in the setup
as it is in being consistent.
But in my opinion,
this is where the cracks in the theory start to appear,
especially when it comes down to some of the statistics.
Many stats end up being useless
due to risk reward and the fat tailed nature of markets.
Even if you have the thousands of samples required
for a statistically significant result,
a simple percentage or average is not going to be enough
to understand what's going on or build a strategy.
So why not just back test it?
Well, that's what I always say.
In this case though, people have a decent excuse.
Generating volume profile requires you
to sort every executed order
into a volume by price data structure
and that takes computing resources.
On top of that,
most retail traders don't have access
to enough historical data.
Most data providers will only provide one year's worth
of the granular order based data necessary
to produce volume profiles.
So we could just be like most people, you know,
and trade it anyways without testing it,
but you know me, we're gonna back test this.
There is a solution and that is to cache it.
You can generate the volume profile,
calculate the key levels
like the daily point of control,
value area high, value area low, et cetera,
and save those levels permanently to a file.
So that's what I did with my indicator
that I created for this video.
Yes, I'm gonna give you more free stuff.
The indicator calculates the daily levels
and puts the result in a CSV file
saved in Ninja Traders cache folder.
So when you look at a day that is already in the cache,
it doesn't have to redo the calculation
every time you back test,
it just grabs it from the file.
The indicator works in back testing,
allowing you to do lightning fast back tests
without the need for tick replay.
It also allows me to calculate these levels
and give them to you going back five to 10 years
so that you can do a proper back test.
And yes, there will be links to download
both the indicator, the example back test,
and the cached data that you will need.
I will put it on Discord
and link it in the video description below.
So while I'm here criticizing volume profile,
I'm also creating one of the best
volume profile resources available
and giving it to you for free.
No, no, no, no, you don't have to thank me.
It would be nice if you click that like button though.
Seriously though,
I want you to be able to do this research on your own.
That way you can run the strategy for yourself
and make as many different variations as you want.
That's what makes this empirical.
You can verify it for yourself.
So I wanted to test a setup
that involves only volume profile.
I found a lot of strategy guides out there
that claim to be volume profile setups
and are really more about things like opening ranges,
et cetera.
We're interested in volume profile.
And yeah, we're going to back test this
over 10 years of data.
I really think that five years is the minimum.
If I wanted to run like a commodities trading pool,
I have to give out five years of data.
So that's why that's my standard.
And trust me, it was not easy to get my hands
on this data and process it into the daily levels,
but I did it cause I'm awesome.
So I actually ended up spending quite a bit of time
trying to find a better setup.
And I did find something
that actually ended up being profitable.
I wouldn't say that the results are great,
but it is profitable.
And the setup was really simple.
It was just,
if you cross below the value area high, enter short.
And if you cross above the value area low,
you go long.
And you can see here from the equity curve,
it is profitable, especially more recently,
although like everything is kind of profitable
recently since 2020.
But a couple of things that I really want to point out,
there is a period from like 2015 to 2019
where it did not do well at all.
So several years where the strategy was ineffective.
So that's definitely something that you want to consider.
Also, when you come over
and you look at some of the numbers, right?
Sharp ratio isn't very good.
This is not a strategy that I would go out
and start a hedge fund with.
You would probably do better
just putting your money into the S&P 500.
But there are some interesting statistical anomalies here.
And remember, the point that I'm trying to make
is not that volume profile is useless.
There does appear to be kind of something to it,
but it seems like with some of the performance
and the other information that we have,
that it's not really the full picture.
But hey, maybe you can improve the strategy.
That's one of the things that drives me nuts
on this kind of video.
There's always that one guy that's like,
well, you didn't backtest every possible combination.
Yeah, you're right.
I only tested a few thousand combinations
with machine learning,
but if I missed something, then why don't you make it?
I've already spent countless hours on this sort of thing
so that you don't have to do it.
We have all of this other empirical data
that we can verify and I want to spend my time there,
but you have everything you need
if you really want to test it more yourself.
So why doesn't this seem to work?
And I believe it's the same problem
that most technical analysis suffers from.
The existence of patterns or statistical abnormalities
doesn't necessarily mean they're predictive.
They're really more the result than the cause of things.
And so we're assigning significance to levels
that are really just arbitrary and random.
I've always found it particularly amusing
that so much attention is paid to the point of control in ES.
For the S&P 500, the point of control
is almost always right around the close
due to the amount of volume traded in the closing auction.
Like, look at this chart.
Here's the close, here's the point of control,
here's the close, here's the point of control.
Any kind of oddity you might find in the statistics
around how price reacts to a previous day's point
of control probably has more to do with volatility
than anything else.
Still, there are some interesting market behaviors in there
that we haven't explained in particular.
Why do we get those Gaussian distributions?
There is an explanation.
So let's get into a more modern understanding of markets.
The new theory that replaces auction theory
is what many of us refer to
as the order flow-driven view of markets.
Its premise is simple.
Orders move markets.
Is your mind blown yet?
Okay, I know that sounds a little overly simplistic,
but working from this simple premise
can reveal big secrets about the market.
So stick with me.
Under this theory, a strong move up or down
is simply the result of orders
and does not necessarily represent some change
in the perception of value among market participants.
Many of the largest players in the markets,
like index funds, are largely price insensitive.
They need to buy or sell a certain amount
to rebalance their fund for the end of the month
or the end of the quarter.
When they buy or sell, it will move the market
despite there being no real change to fair value.
I go into this idea more in my video
on the inelastic theory of markets,
so you can head over there
if you want to learn more about the research behind that.
But there's some other research
I want to get into in this video.
So if price movements do not necessarily reflect changes
in the perception of value among participants,
then why does the market switch
between trending and range bound regimes?
This is where I feel that the ideas
behind auction theory really fail.
People will say that a lot of volume there
indicates interest.
But if a price represents fair value,
why would the majority of the volume trade there?
You don't trade when you think the price is fair,
you trade when you think it's too high or too low.
And this is where the research gets really interesting
because it kind of suggests
that it can happen by accident.
So to better understand this,
let's simplify the market a little
by looking at what is called a Walrasian auction.
And if you think anything like me,
no, this is not an auction with Walruses.
It's named after a French guy named Leon Walras,
who was, am I saying that right?
Listen, it's French.
Anyways, this was an interesting guy,
but I got to focus here, okay?
Stay on topic.
A Walrasian auction is the type of auction used
in the Taiwan stock market.
So participants can only place limit orders
and the orders are all collected for five minutes.
And then at the end of that time, an auction occurs
and the orders are matched up.
And having those set intervals makes it much easier
to model the dynamics going on.
And so you might get something
that looks a little bit like this,
and no, that is not supposed to be a diagram
of party pillows, okay?
So you get these twin peaks here.
That is not any better.
Okay, let's just, let's move on before YouTube gets upset,
okay?
These are the buys, these are the sells.
Orders are matched up
where the buy and sell orders intersect.
Any orders not matched up will be carried forward
to the next auction.
The result is there is less liquidity at current prices
because those orders were already filled
and there's more liquidity
immediately above and below that.
This leads to a situation where it can be difficult
for price to move away from that location.
My favorite way of describing this is that price tends
to settle at where supply and demand are at their minimum.
Clearing a price leaves less liquidity
and makes prices more sensitive to orders.
Outside of that small zone though,
there's a lot of liquidity to push through.
So price just kind of gets stuck
in what I refer to as a liquidity hole.
These dynamics can lead
to certain optimal execution strategies
that those big players we talked about earlier
use to their advantage.
For us retail traders,
a liquidity hole just absolutely sucks
because nobody likes sitting in a trade
that goes nowhere for an hour.
The big players though can take advantage of it
or even create them intentionally.
So the number of contracts or shares
that they need to buy or sell
is more than the available liquidity.
So to execute,
they have to split up their larger order
and execute it in smaller pieces over time.
We call this big order a meta order,
a big order that is split up
and executed in smaller bits.
The execution of large meta orders can take a long time
and this leads to persistent imbalances
between buy and sell orders resulting in trends.
So here's what these guys can do.
They will execute until they create a liquidity hole.
They then scale back the aggressiveness
of their orders and execute within that hole.
They're executing more slowly
but price stays there for a long time.
So they end up executing more volume
in the liquidity hole than they could in other places
and that helps them get a better price.
Hence why these liquidity holes often become
point of controls or volume nodes on the volume profile.
And that's why we get these situations
where price will get stuck in a range
and situations where we'll break out into a trend
and it tends to come in waves.
It's a consequence of how liquidity works
rather than something to do with fair value.
If too much liquidity is cleared at once,
it can result in one of these distributions.
This could be from a large transaction happening there
or from an impulsive sweeping move.
This damages the liquidity in that area
and paradoxically causes prices to get stuck.
You ever had that experience where you get in
because the trend is really getting exciting
and as soon as you enter a position,
it starts going nowhere?
This is why.
Once you understand why these areas form,
you can see why it is kind of silly
to ascribe long-term significance to them.
Once the liquidity in that area has healed,
which rough rule of thumb takes about 45 minutes,
that price holds no significance.
Let's pull it all together.
How can we modify our approach to volume profile
to incorporate this new information?
First, realize that the volume profile
is telling you about past liquidity conditions
rather than past value.
So we can use that information to determine better prices
as well as to time our trades.
If I want to buy,
I'd rather do it at the lower end
of the current distribution.
If I'm looking for a trend,
I don't want to enter just as a liquidity hole forms.
I might want to wait a little bit.
I think a lot of volume profile traders
may already kind of do this subconsciously.
Now you can make such decisions explicitly
because you have a real understanding of the dynamics
going on under the surface.
Also, since the profile doesn't necessarily show us
anything about value, we need to track that separately.
That means following the news, understanding valuations,
looking at closely related comparable assets,
and keeping track of what we think
was driving past moves.
We want to understand when a move really was driven
by a change in the perception of value
and when it was more technical things.
So instead of making theories
about what key levels the market may go to,
I instead recommend making theories
about what flows will drive the market that day.
Flows could be driven by things like breaking news,
but they could also be driven by portfolio rebalancing.
It's not about fundamentals or technicals
or anything like that,
but rather how many orders a particular thing
is likely to generate.
So after our analysis,
if we expect an imbalance in those flows,
then we have an opportunity for a trade.
That should give you some ideas
on how to modify your approach to volume profile
to better align with our current understanding of markets.
If you're interested in the empirically-based
order flow view of markets,
make sure to check out my other videos,
particularly the order flow video series
where we go into all of that.
I also have a free strategy PDF
you can download from speculatorseth.com slash strategy.html.
And this goes into a lot more detail
than a video really allows for.
And of course, I'm always available every morning
during our morning live stream.
I stream my entire trading session
and you can come and ask any questions that you want.
So I will see you guys then
every morning at 8.30 Eastern time.
In the meantime, stay excellent team.
Are you using volume profile slash market profile
in your analysis, in your futures trading?
If so, you need to watch this.